at the start of the first movie a young
man is meticulously sketching an apple
there is no one else in the room and
there is complete silence as the man
finishes up we see a poorly made sketch
implying that he is not an expert just
then something moves inside the closed
cupboard startling
he nervously approaches it thinking that
it is a mouse but to his shock an Apple
has appeared out of nowhere the man is
completely baffled for a while but then
he puts two and two together and
realizes that his sketch has actually
come alive to test his theory he grabs
his notebook and starts sketching a 100
yen Bill once he is done he excitedly
runs to the cupboard when he opens it he
finds the 100 yen Bill there the man
inspects it for a few seconds and
concludes that it is very real he then
excitedly rushes back to his couch and
sketches a stack of money as soon as he
finishes a big wad of cash miraculously
appears inside the cupboard now the man
is rich and powerful and he is an Apple
so all he requires is a beautiful
girlfriend so just like any simp would
he starts sketching a voluptuous woman
however in the midst of it someone
arrives at the door and the man goes to
check he leaves his Notebook on the
table with the sketch incomplete the
woman's head and entire lower half is
missing after a while when the man
returns to the room he hears a sudden
knock the cupboard this is when he
realizes that his incomplete sketch has
come to life the movie ends as a
terrifying hand slowly emerges from the
cupboard nice there's probably boobs in
there the protagonist of the second
movie is an obese and extremely lustful
man named Bing he works as the manager
of a private investigation company but
every time he sees a female client he
loses focus and starts fantasizing about
her Bing has only one aim in life to
have as much coitus as he can normally
he leaves for home at sharp five but
when beautiful women come in seeking
help he could stay until even midnight
the amount of dedication this man has
for his dirty hobby is unparalleled one
day a young woman named Susan visits him
in his office and frantically explains
that her husband has gone missing since
a week ago however Bing is so focused on
Staring at her body parts that he
doesn't even pay attention to her words
he is actually fantasizing about doing
it with her right now when Susan pleads
for help Bing snaps out of his dream and
Promises to start the investigation a
but in reality he doesn't care about her
husband he only wants her later that
night we get to know a bit more about
Bing he has never been married because
he doesn't believe in relationships
whenever he feels aroused he calls his
equally Lusty secretary Gina and does it
with her however he has done her so many
times that he has gotten bored his name
used to be bang but now well you get the
picture the next morning at the office
Bing is doing what he usually does
watching adult movies right then Susan
barges in with some evidence which could
possibly help her find her missing
husband Bing takes it from her and
assures her that they will find the man
then sensing an opportunity he invites
her to a local restaurant for lunch
saying that they can discuss the case
further there as expected a naive Susan
accepts without thinking much about it
shortly after Bing heads to his site
with his Juniors to investigate the
missing man however he quickly gets
bored and decides to take a leak as soon
as Bing unzips his penis though or I
thought that's a penis he is left in
utter disbelief it's almost as if he has
seen a ghost without waste his time Ben
gets into his car and drives off he
receives a call from Susan along the way
but surprisingly he rejects it after a
while he visits his regular doctor and
explains the situation Bing pulls his
pants down and shockingly reveals that
his manhood has shrunk by a considerable
margin sure it has Bing everything was
fine up until this morning but now
things are different unfortunately to
Bing's dismay the doctor is equally
shocked and clueless in all his years of
medical experience he has never
witnessed anything quite like this he
only says I have some Viagra hope it
comes back tomorrow morning so that
night Ben consumes the pills and goes to
bed he even places a camera nearby to
check if something Supernatural is
trying to take away his manhood
unfortunately when he wakes up the next
morning he realizes that the situation
has gotten worse the manhood has
shrunken to an even smaller size soon
he'll have even smaller PP energy than
Bezos terrified by this Bing desperately
tries to seek help hence he goes on a
rampage across the city revealing his
tiny p P to everyone he meets Bing shows
it to a guy at the pharmacy his Junior's
at the office and even random people at
the supermarket when nothing works he
travels to the Himalayas and pleads for
help at a monastery one particular monk
steps forward and says we can beat the
evil out of it oh man this excites Bing
and he urges the monks to initiate the
procedure come on boys beat me off but
all they do is beat him up with sticks
until he falls unconscious in the next
scene Bing visits his doctor once again
and begs for a solution by this time his
manhood is barely visible doc next to me
all other men look like Google
unfortunately the doctor says that there
is no cure for this terrible disease all
Ben can do is pray to God that it
doesn't go away completely however our
protagonist is not going to give up on
his most precious assets so easily that
night before going to sleep he plans to
tie a rope around his manhood good luck
unfortunately at the same time his
secretary Gina barges into the room
looking for some action when she sees
him in the state she is taken aback Gina
can't believe that the manhood she loves
and cherishes so much has now become the
size of a pea suddenly it starts
shrinking again and the two are sent
into a state of panic Gina desperately
tries to hold it with the Rope but it's
too late Bing's manhood has disappeared
Into Thin Air and now he has nothing to
live for the movie ends as a depressed
Gina leaves Bing's room probably because
she is not interested in him anymore on
a Halloween night a young woman is
traveling alone in her car she appears
to be lost and scared as there is
nothing but Wilderness and silence all
around so she takes a U-turn and goes to
the nearest gas station to ask for
directions to her bad luck there is no
one around anxious the woman gets out of
her car and knocks at the door right
then the attendant angrily arrives
chastising a strange looking Cloud the
latter has apparently smeared his
excrement all over the bathroom as the
woman looks in shock and confusion the
attendant threatens to call the cops if
the clown doesn't leave he also warns
that he has a gun which he will not
hesitate to use the statement appears to
anger the clown a bit however he chooses
to leave without causing any commotion
following this the attendant helps the
woman with gas and other necessary
supplies as he is explaining the
directions to her suddenly a loud bang
is heard from the store the attendance
slowly goes inside to inspect but sadly
he never returns after 10 minutes the
woman becomes worried and heads inside
the store as well when she reaches a
certain room she is horrified by which
she sees the clown from earlier has
brutally killed the attendant and now he
is dissecting him bit by bit in the next
scene we see the woman nervously driving
away in her car she tries alerting the
authorities about the murder but due to
bad reception the call doesn't go
through just then she notices the clown
waiting for her on the side of the road
it appears as if he is teleported to the
location fortunately before he can get
to her the woman drives away after a
while she spots a car on the road and
approaches it for help but to her horror
the driver has been assaulted brutally
probably by the same clown this prompts
the woman to quickly get back in her car
and drive away unfortunately as she is
trying to call her boyfriend we see that
the clown has somehow snuck into the
back seat of her car he suddenly puts
plastic over her face trying to
suffocate her but the woman manages to
escape by hitting the brakes abruptly
she then runs into the forest on foot
until she comes across an abandoned
warehouse although it is dark and scary
the woman decides to take her chances
she gets inside and bars the door with a
metal rod soon the clown arrives and
starts banging on the door from the
other side but when he fails to open it
he goes away several hours passed by but
the woman still doesn't have the courage
to go out as she tries to sleep suddenly
the clown appears through the ground and
catches her he then beats her several
times with a whip he calls it his happy
whip causing her in extreme pain however
the woman manages to retaliate by
stabbing the clown with his own knife
she then stabs him a few more times
before running away from there soon the
woman reaches the road where she luckily
finds a passerby seeing her condition he
immediately lets her in and inquires
what happened the woman is unable to
explain anything at the moment and she
simply says let's go please he is coming
unfortunately just after a few seconds
the resilient clown approaches them in
his own car and shoots the passerby dead
as a result the ladder's car loses
control and crashes into a tree when the
woman regains Consciousness she finds
herself in the Clown's operating room to
her horror he has amputated her hands
and legs he has also written several
derogatory words on her body the movie
ends as the clown lets out a maniacal
laugh while the woman screams in horror
jeez that clown is a real bag of [__]
the final movie is set in a dystopian
world where monsters and spirits still
exist one night when a ship is sailing
through a deadly storm it suddenly comes
under attack by a giant crab-like
creature named thanopod using its deadly
claws it quickly kills some of the
sailors forcing the rest of them to
retreat in the cellar later the
survivors conduct a vote to determine
who will confront the thanopod in the
end a shy but cunning man named tauren
is chosen he initially tries to run away
from there but his friends pick him up
and throw him near the bunker where the
thanopod is currently residing having no
options left Torin slowly makes his way
downstairs and confronts the Beast to
his shock the thanopod can now speak
using one of the sailors it had killed
earlier it repeatedly says me need meet
fade an island take me tauren is
terrified by the gruesome sight but he
also gets an idea he makes a deal with
the thanopod he will take it to the
island and in return it will have to
spare him surprisingly the Beast agrees
and backs away leaving a trail of blood
and intestines in its wake torn quickly
goes through the waste until he finds a
special key in the next scene he heads
upstairs and tells his friend friends
that he made a deal but before they can
ask him anymore he rushes to the
Captain's Room and opens a safe using
the key he found earlier tauren then
pulls out a gun and points it at them
demanding them to back off once everyone
calms down he says that he is in charge
from now on one of the sailors tries to
revolt but tauren teaches him a lesson
by throwing him into the bunker where he
is immediately gobbled up by the Beast
after this Torin gathers everyone in his
room and reveals that the thanopod wants
to go to fade an island as there it can
kill a lot of humans and live freely
however tauren has a better idea since
the Beast is not good at geography he
wants to lead it to another Island where
no humans reside the plan is a risky one
but if it works thousands of lives will
be saved however Thorne doesn't want to
take the decision alone so instead he
wants everyone to vote so he hands each
of them a piece of paper and asks them
to choose between the two options after
a while the results come out and tauren
angrily says that two people voted to
take the thanopod to fade an island then
then he pulls out his gun and kills them
in front of everyone after this he dumps
the corpses into the basement which the
thanopod devours immediately the next
morning as everyone is busy with their
work tauren goes to the basement where
he shockingly finds that the thanopod
has laid its eggs now several thousand
tiny creatures are running around the
boat to make matters worse all of them
are hungry and they demand food right
now on the other hand the remaining
Sailors have become tired of torin's
leadership so they plan to eliminate him
they slowly sneak up to his room and
attack him while he is sleeping but it
turns out that he is not in his bed
tauren suddenly arrives behind his
fellow Sailors and kills them one by one
after the massacre he drops all the dead
bodies into the basement where they are
consumed in seconds now only tauren and
another sailor remain however as they
talk he suddenly shoves the Sailor into
the basement revealing that when he
conducted the vote earlier everyone had
voted to take the thanopod to fade an
island none of them wanted to say save
the lives of innocent people at Last
tauren confronts the thanopod himself
and destroys the barrels spilling oil
all over the place then he shoots at the
lantern which immediately catches fire
and sets the place Ablaze following this
he somehow makes it out of the basement
and jumps into the sea where he is
already stationed in a scapegoat the
thanopod on the other hand desperately
tries to escape the basement it breaks
the ceiling and almost manages to get
out but just then an explosion occurs
killing the Beast along with all of its
children the movie ends as the badass
tauren slowly Rose away from the
explosion
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching